well folks I think we may have finally  won the war on Christmas I'm sure Trump  has some responsibility or deserves the  credit and they even want to take away  your beauty  back  but you can now say Merry Christmas  again which of course you always could  even Jewish folks like me were always  allowed to say Merry Christmas uh I  don't even really know what this means  but now with the midterms over and the  cultural stuff back in Focus it's time  to talk about the war on Christmas the  Wright loves it they've been doing it  for more than a decade well the war on  Christmas is not real they tell you it  all the time it's totally fake and if  you believe in it you're dumb I still  don't understand what the hell the war  on Christmas is quite frankly merry  Christmas everybody